alors c'est extrêmement récent ça vient
de tomber c'est arrivé ce matin
la brigade de protection des mineurs la
BPM a interpellé enfin avait en
perquisition CESI les ordinateurs le
matériel électronique de Pierre Palmade
lors des deux perquisitions qu'ils ont
effectuées pour le volet
pédopornographique parce qu'on finit par
s'y perdre dans toutes ses enquêtes
c'est ce matériel a été
analysé et a priori il semblerait qu'ils
en ait extrait au moins deux fichiers
pélope pornographiques
de l'ordinateur de Pierre Palmade
intervient un ami un proche de Pierre
Palma qui se serait servi de son
ordinateur alors là j'ai à l'heure où je
vous parle pas encore le lien entre cet
homme Pierre Palmade et l'ordinateur
mais en tout cas cet homme qui a été
arrêté et placé en garde à vue ce matin
à utiliser l'ordinateur de Pierre
Palmade et cet homme serait un proche de
Pierre Palmas et la question est de
savoir qui a entré ses fichiers pélope
pornographiques dans l'ordinateur il y a
a priori de fortes chances que ce soit
Pierre Palmade
est-ce que ça peut influencer la
décision de demain logiquement non parce
que ces deux choses totalement
différentes
demain la décision c'est en relation
avec l'accident qui a entraîné la mort
de cet enfant qui a entraîné de tout ce
que l'on sait déjà et également sur le
la consommation de stupéfiants donc
logiquement ça n'a rigoureusement rien à
voir même si ça pollue quand même un
petit peu le l'ambiance entre guillemets
ou le dossier ça le teinte alors on me
dit à l'instant apparemment que ce
serait pas Melun
mais à la cour d'appel de Paris la
chambre d'instruction de la cour d'appel
effectivement autant pour moi la
première décision était à Melun et en
cas d'appel effectivement c'est Paris
est-ce que c'est vrai cette info que la
famille aurait appelé un manifester j'ai
pas de alors la famille des victimes
avec envisagé une réunion devant selon
les dernières informations que j'avais
avant finalement pour la sérénité des
débats ils auraient renoncé à manifester
se présenter mais ils ont clairement
demandé que Pierre Palmade soit placé en
détention provisoire la famille a
réitéré cette demande express voilà
moi je suis toujours un petit peu gêné
quand c'est la famille qui demande à la
justice l'incarcération pas
l'incarcation je m'incline évidemment
comme tout le monde autour de ce de ce
plateau devant la douleur de ses
victimes devant l'horreur de ce qu'ils
ont vécu mais la justice est
indépendante et elle ne doit pas à mon à
mon sens être
influencé par la demande d'une famille
parce que vous savez moi j'ai fait des
milliers de des milliers de procès aux
assises par expérience je peux vous dire
que pour les victimes la peine y compris
la perpétuité n'est jamais suffisante
pour les familles des victimes et
évidemment toujours trop pour celle des
accusés donc je pense que les victimes
je respecte une fois de plus leur statut
et je m'incline devant leur douleur mais
ils peuvent pas influencer une décision
judiciaire oui est-ce que je peux
ajouter une précision par rapport au
volley pédopornographie juste avant
c'est que le domicile de l'homme a de 40
ans donc amis de Pierre Palmade a été
perquisitionné à son tour donc ça fait
déjà deux perquisitions chez Pierre
Palmade Paris 3e et ses lits en bière
cette perquisition là et à chaque fois
ils sont sortis très nombreux avec des
ordinateurs de la téléphonie des clés
USB et en fait on peut dire que sur ce
volet là ce qu'on disait avec Benjamin
hier l'étau se resserre quand même
autour de Pierre Palmade dire que là il
y a vraiment deux fichiers il y a une
perquisition donc ils sont en train de
voir effectivement si l'homme avait
accès à l'un des ordinateurs de Pierre
Palmade parce qu'il en a plusieurs mais
le fait qu'on retrouve des fichiers sur
ces ordinateurs quand même là le lanceur
de manière extrêmement rapide dans cette
enquête qui est menée par la brigade de
répression des mineurs à grande grande
enjeux ils vont très très protection des
mineurs ils vont très très vite alors
justement parce que là demain on va
parler de l'accident demain il est joué
pour excellent qu'est-ce qui va se
passer si demain il est remis en voilà
on le remet sous bracelet électronique
et donc et donc après il va être jugé
pour ces images
par rapport aux images pour le moment
les médecins avaient dit il n'est pas
dans un état compatible avec une garde à
vue d'accord donc là il va faire il va
refaire une carte d'anniversaire pour
les images une fois une émission sur
chaque crime ou chaque infraction on
peut faire une garde à vue là vous avez
quatre en état là selon les médecins de
manière il n'était pas pour eux alors en
même temps je pense quand même qu'il
vaut mieux et tous les policiers vous le
confirmeront avoir un type qu'on place
en garde à vue en bon état de santé en
bon état physique quitte à attendre 8
jours il y a pas entre guillemets il y a
pas le feu plutôt que quelqu'un qui est
qui est en mauvais état qui va toutes
les demi-heure ou trois quarts d'heure
je me sens pas bien j'ai mal et ça
risquerait de polluer cette garde à vue
ils s'enfuira pas Pierre Palmade donc si
on fait pas ça y est la garde à vue
demain on la fera dans 8 jours ça à mon
avis ça changera pas grand chose
à ce dossier ça c'est je trouve quelque
chose qu'on a que les gens ont du mal
parce que moi j'ai regardé ça à la
télévision comme tout le monde a du mal
à comprendre qu'on voit les images de
lui sortons du tribunal de Melun qui
sort d'un pas rapide pratiquement au
courant une main dans les poches en
toute décontractions comme s'il allait
au cinéma au restaurant avec des potes
et qu'on me disent qu'ils ça son état
physique n'est pas compatible avec une
garde à vue c'est quand même d'avoir les
mains dans les poches en courant une
main dans les poches alors bah oui
courte distance il voulait pas être
filmé il y avait des caméras de
télévision il y avait des photographes
et je pense qu'il s'est précipité vers
le vers le taxi mais ça ne ça ne préjuge
en rien son état de santé pour avoir 24
voire 48 heures de garde à vue où on va
le questionner et l'intérêt de la pour
la justice l'intérêt c'est qu'on en
sorte le maximum qu'on arrive à avoir un
vrai dialogue que les policiers un vrai
dialogue avec lui et qu'ils aillent
jusqu'au bout de leurs questions s'il
est fatigué s'ils sent pas bien s'il
faut lui faire une piqûre s'il faut des
soins ils vont pas s'en sortir et les
policiers c'est pas des infirmiers si il
n'y avait pas la juxtaposition des
affaires si Pierre Palma n'était pas
déjà hospitalisé bien entendu qu'il
aurait été placé en garde à vue pour la
faire de pédopornographique mais là si
je puis dire pour cette affaire là qui
est très grave potentiellement il est
neutralisé du point de vue de la police
et de la justice il ne peut plus agir
donc il remonte tous les fichiers et
après effectivement quand ils l'auront
en garde à vue là ils auront tout le
matériel pour lui poser des questions
précises c'est pour ça qu'il est même
possible que les policiers eux-mêmes
disent attendons quelques jours on va la
intercepter l'homme perquisitionner
regarder voilà et après on va voir ce
qui se passe il y a moins d'urgence que
dans l'autre à faire Géraldine une
question pour Gilles ou pour Michel les
avocats de Pierre Palmade n'ont pas
communiqué du tout sur l'affaire de
pédopornographie ils sont restés muets
il y a pas eu de communiquer pour nier
les faits
ils n'ont pas communiqué parce que
Pierre Palmade n'a pas été encore
entendu sous le régime de la garde à vue
je sais même pas s'ils ont ils ont
certainement
discuter de ce problème avec lui mais
contrairement à ce que dit Gilles il
parle d'une affaire très grave ce qui
serait très grave c'est si il avait
physiquement abusé des enfants ça a été
évoqué par un quelqu'un qui l'a dénoncé
c'est pas avéré personne n'a retrouvé
c'est c'est ses enfants la détention de
fichiers pélo-pornographique au risque
de tous vous choquer il y a des millions
et des millions de gens qui en ont et
qui ne vont pas en prison et qui sont
juste poursuivis qui ont une amende
on risque des années de prison
de quelqu'un qui a été alors à moins que
ça soit en quantité industrielle mais
après ça
c'est des pensions
il a pris plusieurs années de prison
on sait pas ce que c'est les fichiers ça
se trouve c'est deux petits fichiers
qu'il a récupéré sur le Dark Knight je
suis pas sur l'avocat je cherche pas le
défendre ni à la câbler il est pas jugé
il a même pas été placé en garde à vue
je pense que c'est peut-être un peu tôt
pour
mais voilà
mais c'est pas je pense que le vrai le
vrai problème c'est de savoir s'il y a
eu ces relations avec ce garçon de 7 ans
garçon de 9 ans ça pour l'instant on
n'en sait rien ils n'ont pas été ni
identifiés ni retrouvés
je pense que c'est le noeud du problème
est là sur le volet pédophilie